[Musique]
ce vieux pêcheur pu le certifier toutes
les anglaises qui débarque en france ne
sont pas rousse les a fêtés certains les
bourgeois de calais sont maintenant
d'accord pour leur remettre les clés de
leur bonne ville et pour les accueillir
avec le sourire
on dit aussi que les français plus
exactement les parisiens sont souvent
grincheuse finalement voyez vous ce
n'est pas toujours vrai de toute façon
guère à la hargne à la rogne et à la
grogne est vive l'amabilité et le
sourire tel est le sens de la campagne
1966 de l'accueil de l'amabilité
préconisées par le gouvernement
sur l'initiative de monsieur pierre
dumas secrétaire d'état auprès du
premier ministre chargé du tourisme
vous êtes vraiment très bien placé
puisque vous côtoyez des quantités
d'étrangers est-ce que d'une manière
générale on peut dire qu'en france on
accueille bien les avis sont très
partagés d'avoir un compte 1 avec le
ferons si généralement ici à paris il
est très très difficile du tout le monde
est pressé ce que personnel
frem du top horreur une pauvre étudiant
les français sont en chantier
et dans des renseignements et
quelquefois même quand je ne suis pas
sûr de mon chemin et il vient avec moi
quand je suis venu à paris les premiers
juges et j'ai pris un taxi pour aller à
l'alliance est le monsieur m'a laissé
sur la rue avec toutes mes bagages et
quand je lui ai demandé de m'aider
il m'a dit on même amusé je ne peux pas
laisser le taxi dehors j'aime beaucoup
les parisiens je ne comprends pas
pourquoi on dit que les parisiens sont
pas aimables quand gentil je ne sais pas
c'est peut-être eu de la chance mais
j'ai toujours été très bien reçus des
français accueillent très bien les
personnes qui parle très bien le
français mais qui n'aime pas trop les
personnes qui ne parlent pas trop bien
les français monsieur wiedemann en tant
que responsable de l'american express
compagnie nous avons demandé de
participer à cette séquence car vous
côtoyez disons un très grand nombre
d'étrangers
c'est étrange et formule des critiques
en ce qui concerne l'accueil et
l'amabilité des français j'aimerais que
vous résumer aujourd'hui votre opinion
malheureusement monsieur le ministre on
entend encore trop souvent les touristes
étrangers dire qu'ils sont pas assez
bien accueilli en france surtout par
rapport à l'accueil dans le pays à la sa
périphérie
on a l'impression que le français est un
peu plat zay qui s'attend à voir le
touriste d'arriver tous les ans comme
les aiguilles d'une montre
à une heure donnée et qui n'a pas un
effort particulier à faire pour les
accueillir
je voudrais vous demander ce que vous
comptez faire pour l'encourager à
améliorer son accueil à la vérité nous
comptons le rendre attentif à ce
problème c'est tout le but de la
campagne que chaque français prennent
conscience de la nécessité d'entourer ce
qu'il fait de quelques attentions
on accorde actuellement le plus grand
intérêt à l'emballage et la présentation
des produits manufacturés on cherche à
les rendre séduisant par cette manière
de les présenter au public il faut que
tous les prestataires de services tous
les gens des professions du tourisme se
rendent compte que la prestation qu'ils
rendent elles mêmes
peut trouver beaucoup plus de valeur
vis-à-vis du touriste si elle est
accompagnée des petites attentions du
sourire de l'amabilité qui font plaisir
plutôt que de rx&d là où blasé comme
vous venez de le dire une dernière fois
ses images vous vous rappelez quatre
recettes de bon accueil et d'amabilité
souriante
nous sommes certains que ces qualités
bien françaises seront à l'honneur
pendant toute la durée des vacances sur
nos plages dans nos campagnes et jusque
dans nos chalets de haute montagne
regardez bien ces deux visages souriant
d'une française accueillant une
brésilienne et vous aurez percer tous
les secrets de cette campagne 1966 de
l'accueil et de la mobilité
[Musique]